luego de que la corte internacional de
justicia emitiera este jueves su
sentencia en el caso por las supuestas
violaciones marítimas y soberanas por
parte de colombia contra nicaragua el
presidente colombiano iván duque se
pronunció desde el archipiélago de san
andrés providencia y santa catalina el
mandatario anunció desde allí que por
ningún motivo su gobierno que se
extenderá hasta el próximo 7 de agosto
permitirá que el gobierno de nicaragua
en cabeza de daniel ortega limite el
acceso de la comunidad raizal a las
áreas comprendidas en este archipiélago
y que son destinadas según la aia al uso
económico exclusivo de nicaragua
recordemos que el dominio de 75 mil
kilómetros cuadrados de mar le fue
otorgado a nicaragua mediante el fallo
emitido el 19 de noviembre del año 2012
el llamado que había hecho la corte
internacional de justicia era a que
colombia y nicaragua iniciara un diálogo
bilateral para llegar a un acuerdo sobre
el acceso de la comunidad raizal a estas
aguas sin embargo lo que ha adelantado
nunca es que en los próximos días era un
documento oficial que regirá las
acciones que tomara su mandato sobre
este caso lo que está en disputa también
es el acceso a la zona llamada como luna
verde que es el principal banco pesquero
del área y al cual tradicionalmente los
habitantes del archipiélago recurren
para llevar a cabo acciones de pesca